the microbial fuel cell is an energy
converter it takes one form of energy
and converts it to another form of
energy and in this instance it's a
chemical energy a converted to
electricity we have a live bacteria
inside microwave yourself
they feed on the urine electricity is
produced as the urine gets utilized it's
broken down by the microorganism so what
comes out is cleaner wastewater we could
use it to flush the toilet one of the
microbial fuel cell models that we've
been developing in the lab it's a little
bit expensive it costs about 11 pounds
because it's 3d printed the best that
we've been able to achieve is a ceramic
microbial fuel cell which cost under one
pound sterling for charging a mobile
phone we have done two different things
we have used small microwave yourselves
24 of them to power mobile phone over a
24 hour period we have also used larger
networks yourselves
12 of them to again power the mobile
phone we think that we can develop
microbial fuel cell which can go in back
garden of households take the wastewater
and recycle it to produce electricity
for that household it will take between
five and six years and that's precisely
because we have the the real push from
our sponsors our sponsors being the UK
engineering and Physical Sciences
Research Council as well as the
Technology Strategy Board but we have a
very strong push from the bill amending
the Gates Foundation
you